furman tyler congratulations you boys
have made it into the final round of
this competition now we're sending you
back to your home for just to recreate
this iconic weapon
the u.s army officer sword
oh
the sabrin
gentlemen you'll have four days at your
home forges in which to complete this
challenge at the end of those four days
you'll return and present your sabers to
our panel of expert judges and after
they've thoroughly tested them they'll
move one of you forward to our battle of
the branches final to represent the army
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
four days
thanks good luck
it's day one i'm back at my home forge
in wyo wisconsin
so my plan is gonna be to start out with
a nice 25 plus layer billet of damascus
i've got my stack of 1084 right here
then i've got my stack of 15 n20 here
we're ready to rock and roll and get
this into the forge
i made a log splitter press so that's
given me 22 tons of squish squish
probably cut this into about four bars
which will put us at uh
108 layers restacked
then we'll get them over to the welder
we're so hot in there it's like looking
at the sun
day one's coming to a close i'm just
getting that last bit of length out of
my billet kind of looking like a saber
we got a quench tank i'm hoping the
quench goes well that way i can move on
to the guard
i get that blade into the oil
no pings that's a good sign that's a
very good sign
when i pull the blade out of the quench
the blade actually straightened out
instead of taking a curve so now i'm
under the perimeters
i put my blade back in the heat i bring
it out i put it on the jig that i made
now i don't want to over pull it because
i don't want to break it
i made it
it's day two here on my home forge it's
time to quench
i'm really crossing my fingers here that
everything's gonna go as planned
because i don't wanna have to start over
temperature feels good
got a real real slight warp in the end i
think that's something i can grind out
the file skates
today's the last day i'm starting day
four i'm concentrating on sharpening
that blade and getting the handle done
i'm gonna go with purple heart
one of the highest honors that you can
receive while being in war and surviving
so now a little bit epoxy
we are successful on this one
it's day four here at my home forge uh
plan for the day is to uh finish shaping
my handle get everything polished up put
together and finishing up a blade that
i'm happy with
i rounded off a piece of wood to help me
develop that curve in the guard that's a
good start we're gonna bring out that
damascus
the most rewarding part about making
damascus is going into the acid
i'm just 110 pleased with it the
contrast is great the pattern is awesome
i can't wait to see this blade tested by
the judges hopefully i can hear
tyler welcome back to the forge you
soldiers have had four days at your home
for just to work on your army officer
sabres
now it's time for our weapons test a
strength test a sharpness test and a
kill test
all right soldiers your weapons look
beautiful but were they born to kill to
find that out i'm gonna take your
weapons and deliver slashes and thrust
on this ballistics dummy tyler you're up
first you ready for this ready as i'll
ever be
you need those teeth
at last per uric i knew him well
all right tyler this edge is sharp i
mean just pulling out of that look how
deeply it cut this ballistics dummy now
in cutting the spine and the jaw
it took a little bit of glinting but no
major chips stayed straight
and most of all
it will kill thank you
come in are you ready sir yes sir
[Music]
as soon as i see the band on my blade my
heart stops
all right true means your edge will
lacerate and cut flesh your tip is sharp
to puncture from the back even into the
heart and it lacerates on the way out
but in cutting the head and cutting that
spine
it did take a bend and there's light
chipping on the edge of your blade
but your weapon sir will kill
yeah
bladesmiths
welcome to the strength
to test the strength of your blade and
the overall construction of your sabers
i'm going to beat them violently into
these helmets like they were being worn
by my mortal enemy now i'm not really
concerned about what your saber does to
the helmets or the dummy i want to see
what the helmet and dummy are going to
do to your sabers now furman we're going
to let your blood pressure cool down a
little bit
thank you tyler you're going to go first
you ready
yep
[Music]
well tyler's a beast
you got some chipping on the edge i can
catch my nail on
i don't see any
pulls or delaminations in your steel
still in one piece
it's still sharp good job thank you
okay furman how are you feeling
[Laughter]
well we're gonna do it anyway
[Music]
all right friend and we got two problems
one your blade is just continuing to
bend
pretty soon it's gonna be a 90 degree
angle
uh the other thing is your handle
grooves are shoving my hand
right up against the guard and it's just
bashing my knuckles up into it you can
see
my back two knuckles already starting to
turn blue and swell that's a really big
problem for
[Music]
me gentlemen these tests are
intentionally brutal and severe to set
your blades apart from one another
furman we had a catastrophic failure in
the middle of our strength test and we
just cannot continue testing with that
bent blade
i have to dismiss you from the forge
thank you so much
thank you
i gave it my best
thank you sorry i totally agree with
shouting the test down i wouldn't want
to test it myself and be injured
represent us well hello brother
tyler coming up against you was an honor
i might not be the fortune fire champion
however making it this far
it's been an amazing trip i would love
to do it all over again
go army
tyler congratulations you've earned the
army's and villain our battle of the
branches final competition where you'll
have a chance to win the title of forged
and fire champion for the army and
a check for 50 000
good job brother
feels amazing but this is just the first
step i still got to go up against the
navy the marines and the air force to
prove
that the army can take it all i'm tyler
hackbaugh i'm the army champion and i'm
coming for you guys
mike matt congratulations you've made it
to the next phase in this operation
which means we're sending you back to
your home for just to recreate this
iconic weapon
the united states air force
non-commissioned officer sword
you'll have four days at your home
forges in which to complete this
challenge at the end of four days you'll
return and present your swords to our
panel of expert judges and after they've
put them through the paces they'll move
one e1 to our final battle of the
branches competition
you also need to make a scabbard for
this sword man
i'm just messing with you good luck
blade smiths we'll see you in four days
good luck brother
it's day one it feels great to be back
here in my home forge for this blade i'm
going to be using damascus and i'm going
to try to put in a twist just for fun
a lot of air force ties in how i live my
life day to day and this challenge was
no exception
there's a lot of first for me on this
blade i've never done damascus this long
i've never heat treated anything this
long i've never made a cross guard like
this before it's going to be a bit
stressful for me none of my welds pop so
at least it's a solid billet
so we won't know for sure until we're
grinding into it
but i'm fairly certain it was a
successful twist
i don't think we have any inclusions i
think it's going to look pretty good
so i've got 16 layers now in this billet
i've got it drawn out enough i can cut
it into three sections stack it back on
itself for a total of 48 layers
this is gonna be one of the longest
things i've ever forged so keeping it
straight might be a little bit of a
challenge especially with the twist in
it that could cause some things to warp
all in all a solid finish for day one
[Music]
now that i'm one of two airmen left
i definitely want to be you know the one
that shows that the air force has what
it takes to win the fortune fire branch
competition
the plan for today is to draw the 1084
round stock out
i'm just going to draw lohan on the
floor to give me an idea of how far i'm
drawing it out to start the 1084 steel
was 20 inches i got to draw it out to
about 35 inches
to get the cross guard the handle and
the palm oil
i still got to draw it out quite a bit
with this
27 to 28 inch sword it's going to be
interesting keeping it straight
is a negative 18 outside right now so
i'm ready to get inside and uh turn this
forage on
so yesterday i got the blade drawn out
this morning we're going for the flinch
getting something this long hot
and keeping it straight is uh going to
be one of my biggest challenges right
now
now i got a warping issue
i might be heat treating it again
in the back of your mind you're always
thinking did the heat treat not go well
quenching two times we'll have you know
bad grain structure i have a ton of
concerns
slight warp but at this point
i'm definitely not quenching again
it's the morning of day four i didn't
sleep very well i still need to finish
the pommel i need to finish the cross
guard and i haven't even started the
handle yet
i can tell we're almost through though
almost there
i can feel it
i definitely think this is a blade
worthy of having me stand at the air
force angle in the final round
it is an example of how i problem solve
how i look for solutions and how i don't
give up
all right that's as good as we're gonna
get
day four and today i need to get the
cross guard fitted up the handle shape
wrapped with wire and then the pommel
assembled as well
holy handle looking at the original nco
sword i was trying to figure out what
the best way to make that wire wrapped
handle was safety wire we used that
military i thought that was good to kind
of throw a little air force ism into it
it works perfect i'm definitely nervous
that i have only one day left in the
back of your mind you're always thinking
do i have what it takes to move on to
the battle of the branches i mean that's
what it's all about
that's it
may the best airmen win
all right airmen now we'll take your
weapon and deliver some thrust and
slashes on this ballistic stummy
mike you're up first you ready
absolutely let's do it
[Music]
oh
all right mike
it's a very light sword because of that
you can move with it now your tip allows
for a nice thrust with your edge it
slices i can feel every cut in there but
more importantly
it will kill
thank you all right matt your turn you
ready sir yes sir
nice
all right mats talk about your blade
here
the edge that you have here is very
sharp the point
punctures nicely and most importantly
sir
it'll kill awesome thank you
all right next up the strength test for
that we have ben
hello bladesmiths to test the strength
and durability of your swords as well as
their overall construction i'll be
bashing them into this propeller
mike you're up first you ready
no
we're gonna do it anyway all right
[Music]
well mike
your blade helds up great the only issue
i have with it is that i would really
like this pommel to be bigger if the
pommel were bigger it would give me a
stop but it's got a nice weight
it's still sharp as when it started
really well done thank you so much
matt you're up what are you thinking
ready
[Music]
[Music]
bad
badass
well matt your blade
held up great
it's still sharp
this is a much heavier sword but the
biggest issue i have is with the cross
guard and back your cross guard is loose
it wiggles and also your wire wrap is
loose
but
it's all in one piece it did a heck of a
thing on that propeller well done thank
you well we're not finished yet next up
is the sharpness test and for that i
give you the dug
all right airmen to test the edge of
your blade i'm going to be cutting
across these harnesses
i'm looking for clean cuts
mike you're up first you ready for this
let's do it let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
good job right you're good
sharp all right mike
light and flight and sharp enough to cut
through the harness it's woodcut thanks
sir good job thanks man all right matt
your turn sir are you ready yes sir
[Music]
damn
all right matt let's talk about your
blade here it's kind of heavy
it's so forward in its weight that on
this slash using the last six inches it
just scratched the back of the harness
but on the backhand swing where it's
going all the way through it cut the
harness
but your weapon sir it will cut thanks
good job man thanks
mike matt the blade smith moving forward
is
mike congratulations
thank you
matt first of all thank you for your
service you have a beautiful sword that
did quite well but we based our decision
on the fact that your guard came loose
the weight of your sword and the wire
wrapping is also loose well that's the
reason we're sending it home
yes sir
matt at this time i have to ask you to
please surrender your blade
i feel good no matter what i mean i'm
glad i made it here good job thank you
i'm proud of myself for sure
mike's going to represent the air force
well he's got a lot of people rooting
for him me as well and he's a good
bladesmith so good luck
mike they said you're only as good as
your competition and you overcame a
fantastic competitor to move forward in
this competition to represent the entire
branch of the air force at our battle of
the branches competition how do you feel
feels amazing
please present your blade to the judges
i can't believe i'm the air force
champion i'm looking forward to showing
the rest of the dod what we've got
there's a lot of added pressure moving
forward now i'm competing against the
army the navy and the marine corps we've
got a little bit of a rivalry going on
so you better bring it cause you know
i'm going to
[Music]
trip gene congratulations you fellas
have made it into the next evolution of
this competition now we're sending you
back to your home for just to recreate
this
[Music]
your final challenge is to forge a
marine corps officer's sword also known
as a mammal luke you'll have four days
at your home forges in which to complete
this challenge and at the end of those
four days you'll return and present your
swords to our panel of expert judges and
after they've thoroughly tested them
they'll move one of you forward to
represent the marine corps at the battle
of the branches final competition and
give you that opportunity to win a check
for 50 grand
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
four days
so it's day one i'm back at my home
forge in springfield virginia so i think
the more difficult aspects of the build
are the parameters that i have to build
it to it's very specific and very tight
so we'll see what happens
because the parameters are so tight on
the bend of the blade my crazy idea is
to take a six by six log and then i'm
gonna remove all the excess wood and
it's gonna leave me with a the blade
shape that i want
wow that went better than i thought
i plan on heating up the metal and
whacking it on this log and it's going
to bend and conform to it
i've seen a lot of the smiths straighten
out their blade with this slap on the
anvil so why not try to do it on a big
old log and put an arch in it it seemed
to work pretty well
i like just jumped four hours ahead of
my little schedule
i'm getting ready to heat treat it i
want to keep it thick because i'm
worried about a warp clutching
[Music]
i am exhausted the quench went great
i'm ready to hit the rack
all right so it's day two of getting
ready to jump right into some forging
hammer time
this is a very thin long blade so what's
difficult about a thin and long blade is
just the pure fact that it's gonna warp
i'm constantly having to hammer the big
curves back out and try to keep it
straight as possible all while trying to
draw it out and get the width and the
thickness that i want
it finally meets parameters i'm finally
able to move on to quenching
if i was to pick up a crack that start
over time man this thing could do
anything in the uh clinch here
if this thing snaps
we're gonna be close to being screwed
man
i don't see any warps it looks like it's
pretty straight
super stoked about that
after today i feel pretty damn awesome
day three and i'm ready to get going on
sand casting a guard for my mama luke
sword
i've never done any sand casting before
go big or go home the consistency of the
sand is the big thing
i went with play box sand mix it with
some kitty litter and some water got it
to the right consistency and took a shot
at it
i molded some clay in this rough shape
of a guard and i used that to mold the
sand around i pulled out the clay now
i'm ready to heat up my brass let's go
cast some metal
my mold is ready my brass is a big pool
of molten hot brass i'm ready to pour it
in so i'm gonna go for it
i'm really hoping this sand cast goes
well because i've used a lot of time and
if it doesn't i don't know how i'm going
to recover
moment of truth coming up
holy cow it works i can't believe it i
just got to knock the sand off clean it
up a little bit on the grinder
that's a guard we got a guard
day four man
today i've got to sharpen this blade get
it out of here
my k bar didn't do so well in the rope
cutting test so i want this blade to cut
through whatever those guys are going to
put this thing through
i want that marine core anvil pretty
damn bad just because i want to be able
to represent the marines and the battle
of the branches i believe i can come
home with that 50 grand and represent
the marine corps very well
[Music]
damn
so this is the start of day four so
today i gotta start out with getting it
all fit together
when doug marcaito swings this thing it
is going to slice whatever it goes into
[Music]
i realized i had a little bit more time
left when i wanted to try to put the
names of my competitors on the blade
with some gun blue
rick garrett trip g i'm pretty happy
with it i know it's gonna cut i am done
all right marines welcome to the keel
test
to find out what lethal damage your
weapon will do i'll take your weapon
deliver killing blows to this ballistics
dummy trippy up first you ready for this
get it killer hoorah
[Music]
yikes
[Music]
holy moly
all right trip first up the handle
construction
it is comfortable
your edge here is sharp
even cutting through the skull no issues
at all no chipping no glinting and when
you thrust with this it penetrates and
cuts all the way out overall sir your
weapon
will kill all right hey raw
all right gene you're next you ready
let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh no it bent it
all right gene
your weapon picked up a warp right here
okay your handle coupled with blood all
over made it very slippery and hard to
hold on to because it's blocky and
smooth and i lost my grip on it that's a
very dangerous thing to happen when
you're trying to wield the weapon but
your edge is still sharp your tip is
still frostable and more importantly
it will kill
that'll work
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test so to test the overall
construction of your blade and see if
they're going to hold an edge i'll be
smashing into these
pots now remember this test is not about
what your swords do to those pots for
those pots dude your swords trip you up
you ready ready okay
oh yep holy moly
dog
well tripp
a few things before we get to the
obvious your handle construction is very
comfortable felt really good in my hand
felt like i could do a lot with it
but
right there at the edge there's that
little brown spot
you got a micro crack on that edge yeah
so as soon as i hit that pot it cutlers
i loved it feel its shape and its look
but
obvious problem
all right tripp while i know any marine
could take that blade and still continue
to fight in this competition your blade
suffered a catastrophic failure after
one strike on that vase gene your blade
only has to survive
one strike on these pots
[Music]
the entire marine championship for
forged in fire lies on one swing and
i've got a big old warp in my blade so
it's not over yet
nice job
gene first off you're in one piece
you picked up that bend earlier on
but you didn't pick up any more in this
test strong blade held up good job thank
you
all right tripp looks like
gene's blade held up that means that you
cannot move forward to represent the
marine corps in our next challenge
please leave the forge
super disappointed there's really no way
to tell that you have like any minor
cracks or anything like that so you just
hey you find out when you test them
that's how we found out today yeah
brother james gonna freaking bring home
that battle of the branches marine corps
anfield he's winning it for the marine
corps
gene congratulations you've won this
competition and that means that you're
going to be moving forward into our
battle of the branches final competition
to represent the marine corps at the
marine corps zanville and that's going
to give you an opportunity to win a
check for 50 000 good job brother
holy cow i did not see this coming it's
been a fun ride up until now but now i
got to represent the marines
so now it's it's game on and it's about
to get real those other brand service
members better look out
jared lee congratulations you guys have
made it into the next phase of this
selection process what you're fighting
for is the navy anvil at the battle of
the branch's final competition and a
chance to win fifty thousand dollars and
now we're sending you back to your home
forges to recreate this military weapon
from history
u.s naval officer sword
awesome
you'll have four days at your home
forges in which to complete all these
parameters at the end of those four days
you'll return and present your blades to
our panel of expert judges after they've
expertly tested them they'll push one of
you forward into the battle of the
branches competition
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
four days
today is day one and today i'm working
on boarding out the basic shape of the
sword and maybe get the heat tree
navy way is uh slowest smooth start slow
and it will turn into speed and
perfection later on
i got my sword shaped out and i'm ready
for uh heat treat
into day one no cracks i'm feeling
pretty good i'm sitting well right now
yup that is sexy all right
first thing i'm gonna do today is use my
rotary tool and hand grind in my fuller
[Music]
for a hand fuller
can't ask for much better
blades ready to be quenched
the one thing you always think about is
don't snap this is the moment you don't
have a warp snaps are fatal warps are
critical but it can be fixed
pull it out
oh
it's hard but it's got a bow
to the jig i have to get it in my
straightening jig to see if we can get
that pulled down let's hope it
straightened it if not we gotta go
through that whole thing again
pick it up look down it bam we got a
straight blade ten minutes bladesmiths
you have ten tiny minutes
so as of right now my plan is to get
some sheet steel use that for the
majority of the leaf guard and then
getting some steel for the knuckle guard
and braiding it kind of give it a
nautical naval theme to it
try and make it look like some rope or
line
this wire is bulking up way more than i
thought it would be
i'm trying to braid this thing it's not
moving the way i want it to
i didn't want nearly as many gaps as
this so i'm starting to get a little
frustrated
i still have a whole lot to do but at
the end of the day i'm treating this as
if this is a fifty thousand dollar sword
so i'm gonna put every ounce of energy i
have into it
i decided i'm just gonna stick this in
the vise and uh start twisting
until it looks like rope all right
first things first put the coffee down
pick sword up tempered last night and
the warp that i thought i had fixed came
back in the temper overnight
right down the edge right down that
spine i have to get this fixed before i
move on with the sword
to get this warp out i'm gonna have to
pin it
heat up the spine then let it relax and
hopefully the warp will come out
a little tap but i can live with that it
don't rock finally get this warp out
still hard it's time to move on to the
handle material
i set up the micara handles by cutting
them rough shape to fit the handle
drill the holes
like that i think i need to get the
pommel so when i do make the guard
a knuckle bow i know where to end it so
i need the pommel next
it's pretty blade heavy and it's gonna
need a big chunk of brass to be able to
balance that out done
all right sailors your weapons looks
beautiful but it's time to find out if
they're wall hangers or they're actually
something you could use to kill
jared you're first you ready for this
i'm ready let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
all right jared the balance you have
here
feels good in the hand now your edge is
very sharp as you can see with every cut
it cuts deep for every thrust all the
way through and true overall sir your
weapon
will kill
thank you good job
all right lee it's your turn you ready
yes sir let's do this
that's a lot of hog to go through with a
skinny blade i'm pretty nervous
good job thanks
all right
the handle construction is comfortable
your edge not one
single glint or rolling your tip
punctures and cuts on the way out and
overall sir
it will kill yes
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the dreaded flex test
so to test the strength of your blade
i'll be bending it in both directions
up to that red point
jared you ready for this i guess okay
[Laughter]
i'm impressed
uh your blade is just as straight as
when we started the test
that's a really nice heat treat thank
you holding your sword
you can shorten that handle just a
little bit scale wise but at the same
time it winds up being fairly
comfortable nicely done thanks
all right lee you're up you ready for
this yes sir okay
the longest five seconds of my life
nice job lane that blade is still the
same shape it started it that's
impressive thank you sir really good
all right gentlemen it's time for the
sharpness test we call this the fish
slice
we're going to be lowering those fish
down i'm just going to start cutting i'm
going to keep cutting till i run out of
fish all right jared you're up first are
you ready i'm ready okay
[Music]
this is why i love sabers
they are just so much fun to cut with
it's just passing right through the fish
beautifully your handle construction
might be a little bit
wide but it's comfortable and it stays
in my hand i think you did a great job
thank you
lee you ready
yes sir okay
[Music]
[Music]
all right lee cuts beautifully i mean
the edge on this
is wonderful
saber's definitely sharp and a great
balance nicely done thanks sir
jared and i are neck and neck i mean
both blades performed great
jared lee only one of you can move
forward and that smith
is lee congratulations you'll be moving
forward to represent the united states
navy in the battle of the branch's final
competition congratulations good job
thank you
jared unfortunately your blade didn't
make the cut and david baker's going to
tell you why jared you brought us an
effective cutting sword but this came
down to the basic details of
aesthetics and the way that weapon felt
in my hand i understand
well jared come on forward brother
good job man this competition was such a
learning experience for me
uh made a lot of good friends i had a
great time came out good job [ __ ] mate
i didn't win but i did through a very
awesome sword
lee you did well give him hell and take
it home from the navy
lee congratulations you've forged your
way into this final competition where
you'll compete against the air force
army and marine corps to bring home the
title a forged and fire champion to the
united states navy and you'll also be
competing to receive a check for 50 000
you've done a fantastic job you're only
halfway there
and we'll see you real soon
good job thank you sir i just won
really really really
being able to represent the navy is
an honor i am totally ready to do this
all over again and i'm going to tell you
guys to bring your eight game because
i'm bringing mine
bladesmiths congratulations you fellas
have made it into the final round of
this competition now we're sending you
back to your home forges to recreate
this iconic weapon from history
general george washington's lion-headed
kutto
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
four days
so my bill is going to be made out of
1084
and 15 and 20. really good contrasting
steals for damascus
the last time i did my saber build for
the army episode i went with the
damascus the damascus it is a risk
because there's multiple things that
could go wrong from cold shots to stress
fractures but as long as my blade does
perform as i expect it to my damascus is
going to be that thing that puts me over
the top
here we are again back in springfield
virginia at my home forge the plan for
today is to cut out a billet for the
sword
so this wood anvil as they call under
the log whap method
they put a gentle ark in the blade
that's the same log that i used for the
mammal luke sword for the marine
competition
it worked before if it's not broken
don't fix it
[Music]
day two i gotta get this blade quenched
today and i'm gonna make some changes to
the way i do it in my forge i'm gonna
try using the tube method
main goal is to take this tube and just
turn it into a nice long hot oven
had a little bit of issues getting even
heat last time
so i think with that tube it should give
me a nice more even controlled heat
i don't hear any cracks pings or
anything like that
i nailed it it's exactly what i needed
to be
[Music]
anyway
day four finally here
i'm feeling ready i have a plan and i
have some hurdles to get over the
biggest one roars is that lion head
pommel first thing this morning i'm
gonna put that thing in plaster paris
and let it set
i wonder if i should do it with pewter
you don't have to get pewter nearly as
hot
it'll be shiny it looks just like silver
looks like garbage
i think i'm gonna go with the silver one
just because of the look of the silver
right now i need to finish the line head
polish everything
and sharpen the blade try to take some
weight off anywhere that i possibly can
and then put it all together
whoa done it's done
day four final day
i've never carved a problem before so i
don't know how long it's gonna take and
i'm gonna have to put some time into it
so i'm just
profiling from one way right now the
shape of the lion's head
to kind of refine it to what my final
shape is going to be
and then i start removing some more
material a little fine-tuning with my
rotary tool
pretty much looks like a lion to me
all right veterans welcome to the keel
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
weapon deliver killing blows to this big
carcass that you're up first ready
[Laughter]
i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
all right tyler your handle construction
just right
your edge is very sharp
overall sir
this saber
will kill perfect
all right gene your turn sir you ready
let's do this doug
[Music]
all right genes this is a heavy sword
very forward heavy but when you have a
forward heavy blade that you're hitting
it meets resistance
a cylindrical
almost
circular handle
makes a twist in my hand so probably
this is the reason why the chain came
off
but your blade is sharp it will kill
all right gentlemen december 25th 1776
george washington leads the continental
army across a frozen delaware river to
attack the hessians at trenton new
jersey and he probably didn't chip his
way through the ice but that's not going
to keep us from our strength test the
ice block chop
tyler you're up first are you ready uh
yeah yeah let's do it
[Music]
all right so tyler your chain fell off
but there's no damage on your edge
your handle is comfortable other than
the chain you nailed it
all right gene
do it
[Music]
all right gene your blades edge
is still there and it's still sharp the
issue is
uh the rest of your chain fell off and
it's picked up a bend i have less issue
with that and more issue
with this polished handle it's just hard
to hold on to
but
it is strong
and does have an edge so good job
all right veterans our sharpness test
today is the hessian charge
this is all about what your edge will do
to these gummies
salary up first you ready for this yep
[Music]
[Music]
all right tyler the weight of your
weapon does prevent me from going very
fast but you have a very sharp edge all
the way through your weapon website it
will cut thank you
all right gene it's your turn sir are
you ready let's do this doug
[Music]
all right gene to be able to maintain a
good grip on this more of the cuts i
create are more impact as opposed to a
slash where it cuts all the way through
so you have some cuts here that are more
nicks
deep nicks because you have a very sharp
edge
and for this tester your weapon
will cut
awesome tyler gene first of all i want
to thank you both for your service
you're both champions in my mind you've
already won your branch divisions but
there can only be one battle of the
branches champion
and you'll walk out of here with a check
for fifty thousand dollars
and that champion is
tyler congratulations you are the battle
of the branches forged and fire champion
gene
please surrender your blade
there's a lot of marines out there and
there's a lot of great guys in the
marine corps and so for me to stand here
and represent them is pretty humbling
i learned too that it's not about uh
just the mello bean forged in fire i
feel like i've been forged in fire and
it's how you handle the ups and downs
the wins the losses and it'll determine
real quick how you've been heat treated
throughout your life
tyler congratulations you overcame every
obstacle set in front of you you beat
out all the other smiths and now you're
the battle of the branches forged and
fired champion that's a title that comes
with a check for 50 000
and most importantly
bragging rights
good job my brother please present your
blade to the judges
i'm super excited when this whole thing
started i had no idea how it was all
going to turn out it feels good to
have represented the army the fact that
i just won fifty thousand dollars is
starting to set in
i'm sergeant tyler hackmart and i'm the
new battle of the branches champion
you